[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing one of the staples of
hogwarts
the sorting hat the sorting hat at
hogwarts is first introduced to students
at the sorting ceremony a rite of
passage where students are assigned to
the house that will be their family for
the duration of their time spent
at the school the role of the sorting
hat is simple
assign hogwarts students to their houses
there are four houses
gryffindor hufflepuff ravenclaw and
slytherin
and each of these four houses value
different qualities in people
the hat is a sentient being that
originally belonged to godric gryffindor
before being sentient however it was
just a regular hat
then it was enchanted by godric and the
other three fans of hogwarts
rowena ravenclaw helga hufflepuff and
salazar slytherin
to perform its task of sorting students
the hat uses
legitimacy which is the art of magically
navigating through a person's mind
someone who is proficient at practicing
legitimacy is referred to
as a legilimens the hat will navigate
the layers of the wearer's mind
and after careful consideration announce
its decision loudly
so that all can hear after founding the
school the four founders encountered a
bit of dilemma when it occurred to them
that they would have to figure out a way
to sort students by house
when they were no longer alive however
this dilemma was short-lived
as godric gryffindor quickly provided a
solution to their problem
with his hat the founders of hogwarts
recognized that they each valued very
different virtues
virtues which ended up leading to the
defining attributes of each house
it was important to them that the houses
that they founded would continue to
follow by the beliefs from which they
were based
these values or inherent characteristics
can be summed up in the sorting hats own
words
by gryffindor the bravest were priced
far beyond the rest
for ravenclaw the cleverest would always
be the best
for hufflepuff hard workers were most
worthy of admission
and power hungry slytherin loved those
of great ambition
it has been speculated that the hat has
a tendency to place students in houses
based on the qualities they value
and not necessarily the qualities that
they actively personify
additionally the hat can detect nascent
qualities in a student
and generally places them in the house
that will challenge them the most
putting their character to the test but
one thing that i've often asked myself
is is it possible to beat the sorting
hat
since it uses legitimacy are you able to
influence the decision that the sorting
hat ultimately makes
or is it left entirely after the hat
baltimore gives us a little more info on
this
the sorting hat is notorious for
refusing to admit it has made a mistake
in its sorting of a student
on those occasions when slytherins
behave altruistically or selflessly
when ravenclaws flank all their exams
when hufflepuffs prove lazy yet
academically gifted
and when gryffindors exhibit cowardice
the hat steadfastly backs its original
decision
on balance however the hat has made
remarkably few errors of judgment
over the many centuries it has been at
work so the hat is stubborn and
it knows best this leaves little room
for the hat to consider
what you want or where you feel you fit
this means that no
you cannot influence the hat's decision
in any way
i would imagine that if you were an
older witch or wizard and practice
oklahomans
then you could somewhat influence the
hat's decision since it uses legitimacy
but i'm willing to bet that no brand new
students at hogwarts
are experienced oclumens additionally
there are several indicators from the
text which seem to suggest that once the
hat has made its decision
there is no available recourse first
when ron discusses what he would do if
he was sorted into slytherin
i always knew salazar said therein was a
twisted old loony
ron told harry and hermione as they
fought their way through the teeming
corridors at the end of the lesson
to drop off their bags before dinner but
i never knew he started all this
pureblood stuff
i wouldn't be in his house if he paid me
honestly if the sorting had tried to put
me in slytherin
i'd have got the train straight back
home and next when draco discusses his
recourse if he was somehow sorted into a
house other than slytherin
well no one really knows until they get
there do they
but i know i'll be in slytherin all our
family have been
imagine being in hufflepuff i think i'd
leave wouldn't you
since both boys mention leaving the
school all together
this tells me that once the hat has made
up its decision there is no turning back
that is your house whether you like it
or not one other thing that should be
mentioned
is that every so often a hat stall will
occur this is when the sorting hat takes
longer
more than five minutes to be exact to
make its decision
this generally only occurs every 50
years or so and is very uncommon
a hat stall occurs when a student has a
personality that could be considered
equally suitable for more than one house
as if this is the case the hat needs to
examine the student more closely
which takes more time harry potter among
other students
were near hat's tools meaning the hat
took longer than usual
but not quite five minutes when harry is
first sorted
he wants nothing more than to be in
gryffindor and verbally expresses that
he has no interest
in being sorted into slytherin hmm said
a small voice in his ear
difficult very difficult plenty of
courage i see
not a bad mind either there's talent oh
my goodness yes
and a nice thirst to prove yourself now
that's interesting
so where shall i put you harry gripped
the edges of the stool and thought
not slytherin not slytherin not
slytherin a
said the small voice are you sure you
could be great
you know it's all here in your head and
slytherin will help you on the way to
greatness
no doubt about that no well if you're
sure
better be gryffindor and while it seems
like the hat is taking harry's decision
into its consideration
it really isn't all that happened after
harry uttered
not southern was the hat making up its
mind entirely of its own volition
that gryffindor just happened to be a
better fit it was really nothing to do
with what harry wanted
so if you want to be in a particular
house at hogwarts
you better hope that the values of the
house correspond with your own
and if you can't handle where you're
sorted then just pack your bags
because the hat isn't changing its mind
and that's it for this video
if you enjoyed the content please like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you